you're picking to be a single parent  without even trying no it's one thing  it's one thing okay to be in love and  then you guys can't work it out and then  later I mean I still think you should  work it out that that's a whole nother  conversation but that's that's a  separate situation than going in and  saying you know what I don't think I can  get along with a man so but because I  want a kid I'm gonna raise him in a  situation where they're they're in two  separate houses which we know which we  know isn't good for the kids okay  because otherwise it's going to be toxic  like why why is it it's going to be a  toxic situation  why can't it just be that you try to get  along with the guy friend it's the same